hi hey hello my name is Kiera chambers
and I'm Cody Melchior and this is Tara
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
Verbinski leave no that means is the
director of the first three Oh
we is pirates of the caribbean dead men
tell no tales thank you I think that's
what it's called
it's about dead people they don't talk
cuz they're dead
but they do talk but they can't because
they're dead and then I loud tell tales
because that's some sort of weird thing
because the dead didn't tell no tales
thing is supposed to be about how dead
people can't talk but I don't know if
you guys know about this franchise debut
will plot all the time in this franchise
tell again during the film I was like oh
this is clever no country for old dead
men that telltale - oh my go smart
summer don't say that you're right okay
well but I did all I have is Javier
Bardem more like Javier boredom Leah
toys we have commentary and we have it
all
- Chris just to give a little background
of what we've done what have we done why
retired we've spent the last two days
watching the three days three days
scientists at first for Pirates of the
Caribbean Caribbean movie written like
Hazzard galloping about the excitement
is indicator is palpable because wanna
see our thoughts on the first floor
movies i released a video of log on my
personal channel personally I grew up
with one like one with a big deal in my
movie going experience I think 2003 is
when it came out I remember being very
excited for this very central haunted
mansion way more impressed by this than
javed vision and so this is like this
weird throwback to me being 12 and like
wanting wanting this in my life you know
a lot of things are making sense about
Tamra it results are sort of a part of
you
giant giant big big parts it feels like
oh my god you're like what yeah I saw
the first one I don't know if I thought
when it came out I know I saw it at some
point I feel like I saw him in high
school or something it's time
they've always seems fun from afar
mm-hmm that is such a good way to put it
I think the idea of the franchise and
the characters that are presented I like
at first glance are really exciting and
then you get more into the series were
integrated into the actual stories we're
like oh the three hour movie maybe it'll
be really interesting to driven
interested it doesn't really meet that
marked for me we have an accord
yeah not more inaccurate they set it up
the whole time right together the court
and every type odium community card and
I definitely read more about some guy I
knew let's talk about this I'll do it
laughs all right man and talk about it I
think it's way better than three or four
it was definitely shorter that's just
science it was more engaging I think I
enjoyed seeing the original characters
back where we missed them and for I
think four was a kind of a flop just
because we trying to introduce too much
too many new things so this was exciting
to see those old things I think it
resolved some things nicely we talked
about it a bit while marathoning the
movies said this franchise is something
that people really liked because of the
nostalgia with it and they really enjoy
because they want to enjoy it they like
the idea of it and I sang with me I like
the idea of it I don't think it
necessarily delivers all the time
so this while it was a two hour movie
not too long which I really appreciate
it thank you so much for nothing three
hours I didn't have a terrible time
watching it it was simpler to like what
I saw leagues a great wall it was just
kind of like laughs I didn't need this
this was kind of unnecessary but it
wasn't bad like it it made it it just
wasn't something that was like
fanservice I mean
it's not to do this now I needed to like
be able to resolve all of my questions
in this franchise know it like it was
just whatever it's a fun enough movie
but not one that I need to watch
immediately again or that I really would
want to like that I'd be like really
like telling people like not to keep
preparing expansion furious but fast
furious and pirates and two franchises
that I've delved into heavily without
having really dealt with them before
forth from the Ceres and Bacchus and the
spate of furious I left that movie and
like told my parents to go see it like I
was like everybody like I would have
seen it in theatres that week again
because I really enjoyed it I love fun
um I really like a lot of the components
of the pirate parts of the Caribbean
franchise I like the Pirates I like I
like a lot of I like a lot of the visual
they do a really good job of creating a
world the world building stuff in
Pirates of the Caribbean
I love certain characters and even the
characters that I don't love I really
like and appreciate like man I think
everything fits really well together the
only problem that I ever really have is
it just has kind of an underlying
staleness to it sometimes which i think
has to do a lot with the actual like
script in terms of dialogues and and
like and just kind of action like when
you when you're hanging out with an old
friend and you used to be like best
friends and it's been you know six years
and second we have it yeah and you
haven't talked a long time and then you
just like you get coffee but you just
realized that your lives have become so
different so ever part yeah that was the
Pirates franchise felt like to me yeah
there was just something not there and I
could tell that I still really
appreciated it and I could tell that I
still really enjoyed kind of being there
that's exactly what it is I think 7 this
honey honey there's a lot of I tried to
look if there was a supercut of all of
the times with John
Savion YouTube and there's not something
get on that Internet how do we make that
the main mission is to find to sign his
Trident and you've got the new love
interest to build upon the old love
interests and you could see what they
were trying to do which really hit the
mark like I didn't care about this will
Turner's son
I think Here I am I didn't I wanted to
love the girl who loved science and he
was called a witch I wanted to love her
I heard some characters it's like so up
my alley so something that I am all
about and she just didn't quite hit the
mark and I don't think it's her I'm not
going to be just acting I think for most
of it it's a script thing and I feel
that way about a lot of the Pirates
movies it felt it felt this particular
one felt overly formal formulaic on that
time yeah it felt like a really fun of
pirates movie that had this different
rock like rom-com shoved into italy and
like it's like they were trying to find
like a third key for the pirates movie
and they found a weird rom-com script
and they were like alright well let's
just let us overlay this into it I
really liked shoehorned an attempt to
recapture pirates one in some way weird
like let's just try to remake pirates
one kind of tow and and I agree I didn't
really ever feel connected with will son
and I didn't and I I liked her enough
but not in fit she never got there she's
like whatever on her okay fine they
never be really strong characters and
you throw them into the middle of two
characters who have not only been
engaging with each other for over a
decade that AI leaders yeah but also
characters that we fit engaging with for
over a decade
yeah and are also incredibly strong
personality and then growing on top of
that are you have your bird is
displaying an incredibly strong
character tune and it's just like they
kind of get lost in the like the ocean I
think annoyed me so much because I
really wanted her to be strong because I
wasn't a humongous fan of Elizabeth
Swann I was not a fan of Penelope Cruz
the one jopen they did a call back
through that I really did like without
Clary
like the first kinda did the joke with
her her getting rid of the rum it's a
very comfortable franchise having not
having only key the first movie a very
long time ago not really knowing much
about it other than tangential stuff I
heard or seen places yeah it's a
franchise words like yeah I could just
really I really easily kick back with
Tamara and we watch the whole franchise
mate and it was just fun and enjoyable
it's all like a ride that's a lot like
Malala when you get down to it that's
what you want oh my god sorry you're not
affected me or myself effort I didn't
think it bogged down by time and a lot
of the film the things that they allow
themselves to like really indulge in
things that they don't need to indulge
in and it just is like okay I'm just
going to cut like half a bit and it
would've been fine but what you enjoying
it is I every time it's amazing to ride
it with on screen we about famine yeah I
was fun
I don't fun it is fun of them want me
that I don't want to see things from the
rides with a good part of the movie are
the great parts of the movie and then
it's like there's and then the problem
it's just that something connected
together is not as strong so that makes
it to make it harder but I mean I
Barbosa is my single favorite character
of the whole franchise and I loved him
in this movie yeah I thought Javier
Bardem character was a great character
it's half the time that Jack Sparrow
accomplishes something in the whole
franchise it's because Barbosa has saved
him in some command right or like really
helped out yeah and then like when left
to like their own devices to just be
people Barbosa constantly proved like in
the interim between movies robos always
proves that he's just a way better
pirate whenever there's not a pirate of
the Caribbean movie occurring like this
is like on the all-time pirating barbosa
is always killing it in the library
the person as a person ranked as a
pirate yeah he liked their Barbosa
Barbosa is like the Niles crane of
Pirates of the Caribbean he is had a
much stronger arc he's changed more as a
character he has done more as a person
and like has experienced more growth and
has more interest and stuff
and it's just like amazing that look
like well I sort out I was like I like
geoffrey rush a lot you know Casanova
Frankenstein sure thing rock and roll
and then for mostly definitely I did up
loving Barbosa game like I'm not even
like that crazy about this franchise I
love I like the franchise again like
pirates whatever but I might actually
get up Argos a Funko pop because I like
I ever did love that dude stay for the
end there's an after scene credit which
just is confusing yes and that's enough
to me that fit spoilers this franchise
is continuing oh it was it was fun
enough it was way better than three or
four I think and I'm so glad for that
and I hope they get better I want to
like this franchise I want to love it
I like it I want to love it hello Ike
goodbye Ike oh no he's still here I
wanted to say something oh ho ho and a
bottle of fun savvy
what were we reading next week um I
think I think is Wonder Woman wonderful
[Applause]
[Music]
we're going to tiny Cape I'm going to go
in my Wonder Woman oh that's great thank
you for watching me this means thank you
for having me it was painful the times
that I know that and so I appreciate you
all the more
[Music]